hello everyone today's Alan's 50th
birthday and a lot of you have requested
a game for for this special occasion I
had to decide which game to choose since
we already covered unand versus versus
our onion the 2013 Tata Steel game twice
so we can show that again but we do have
a very special game it's from the 1995
Anand Kasparov well sort of a vulture
Championship match was not held under
fee day but under the professional chess
Association and it's it's really an
intense game before we check that out a
lot of people are congratulating on and
on all the social platform so I would
just like to show one of the one of the
I thought were nicer ones so here's a
nice congratulations from you did polgár
she posted this photo of her and Vichy
which is 18 years old here she says
speedy Vichy at age 18 sharper talent
and Eddy but anybody I knew a role model
for the upcoming generation in India and
around the world
thanks for the fighting games happy 50th
birthday to a unique personality and
world champion Vishy Anand so there you
have it and also I will include if you
wish to check out some other
congratulations a link in the
description below a nice video for
congratulating Anand was done by the
Greenwich grantee just classic video
team and a lot of very important people
in the chess world are featured in the
video such as the Magnus Carlsen and
Gary Kasparov Peter Svidler you did
polgár amongst others and well there are
just so many of them and even I am
feature featured for for a few seconds
so if you want to check it out it will
be the first link in the description
below so that being said this is game 9
from their 1995 match and the first 8
games ended in a draw now the game was
played on the observation deck of the
107 floor of the World Trade Center in
New York and the prize fund was a
million and a half dollars so that being
said we're probably gonna cover this
game once more when we will do the
dionan saga
who knows maybe maybe in a few years but
until then we let's just enjoy it so
this is game 9 Anand with the white
pieces opens with E 4 sorry about that
we have c5 by Kasparov so this is silly
in defense Knight to f3 d6 and now B for
C characters Knight captures so
everything is fairly standard Knight of
6 we have Knight to c3 and a6 now Bishop
to e2 and ecigs does Haven in a
variation we have castles by white and
now Bishop to e7 so this is the the
mainest of the main lines we have a for
preventing b5 and Knight to c6 now
Bishop to e3 by Anand continuing
development we have castles by Kasparov
and now f4 we have Queen to c7 and now
King to h1 a nice prophylactic move
which you usually want to do when this
diagonal is opened up we have looked
eight and now Bishop to f3 strengthening
the center putting the bishop tool to a
better diagonal Bishop to Bishop to d7
by Kasparov and now nice the b3 avoiding
any exchanges in the center and also you
will at some point regain will not
regain but gain very nice control of the
b6 square and here b6 is the mood that
is being played today this is considered
to be the main line and everyone plays
this but in 1995 Kasparov played Knight
to a5 he wants to trade a pair of
Knights we she obliges we have Knight
characters Queen captures and now Queen
to d3 developing the Queen and now
making room for this rook to come to d1
we have rook 8 d 8 by Kasparov and rook
F to D 1 with the ship to c6 and here
comes a B 4 by Vishu so it's a it's a
nice move that kicks away the Queen and
prepares to b5 since the pawn cannot be
captured if you capture it then just
rook a B 1 and now it doesn't matter
where you go if you go to a 5 then there
should be six traps the Queen there are
no squares available as you can see the
pawns cover D squares night covers that
the shrub covers b6 and the bishop this
book covers h5 so the Queen would be
trapped here and also if you go to a
three then it's just rugby 3 again traps
the Queen the night covers a 2 and a 4
so Kasparov forced to retreat with Queen
to c7 and now comes b5 so you don't
really gain anything by capturing if
captures captures then you just allow
rope to a 7 so here cuz paarvo goes back
Bishop this
and now rook a to be one we have a
captures my Kasparov now Knight captures
on b5 attacking the Queen Bishop
captures on b5 Queen captures and the
now rook to e8 you cannot capture on c2
as you would again blunder your Queen
just rogue D 2 c1 you attack the Queen
Queen a2 and not work the a1 and the
Queen has no squares all of this is
covered and the the bishop pair nicely
covers these squares so after Queen
Queen captures on b5 we have looked a 8
now maybe with ideas of rock a5 maybe
bring the other Brooke to AAA to go
after the e4 pawn but first run goes c4
takes further control of the d5 square
and prepares a 5 for the moment you
cannot play it but Bishop to b6 is
coming which will help with with playing
of a5 so first we have a 5 by Kasparov
Bishop to b6 pushing the Queen back
Quintus e8 and now F captures on e5 e
captures a D captures on e5 and now you
could capture on e5 with the Queen but
then you lose the a for pawn so first
Anand pushes a 5 now it's nicely
protected here and now threatening just
Queen captures pawn on e5 so Kasparov
defends it with Bishop to f8 and the now
comes h3 taking away the g4 square from
the Black Knight if the knight is
allowed here then a lot of other squares
will become compromised we have Queen to
b6 by Kasparov and now Anand has to
decide how to continue this game there
are there are there are some ways you
can continue like this with the c7 you
can add another attacker here create
some threats against the b7 point but
Anand chooses the move that basically
made this game what it is and it is the
deposition from the thumbnail so here on
place rook to d5 so what do you do here
if you do not think I don't will just
double rooks here then he can trade on
d8 so how can you continue this without
capturing let's let's explore that
briefly first so let's say you play
something like h6 you try and make a
useful move or g6 or something rugby d1
again if you really don't
want to capture this rook and allow
Island to have a passed pawn on the
d-file rook a c8 and now you can just go
rogue d8 let's say rook captures on c4
rook captures on e8 Knight captures any
eight and now Bishop to g4 pushes the
Queen away from the defense of the e5
pawn but also the Queen has to keep an
eye on the rook and c4 so Queen c6 and
now you pick up the e5 pawn and you get
this position the material is equal well
the position is supposed to be equal not
not only material-wise but Anand has the
bishop pair and Kasparov doesn't seem to
enjoy enjoy this position to go for it
so he just grabs it Knight captures on
d5 and it's not a mistake or anything
it's it's a move you should play in this
position so e captures on d5 and now
Queen to g6 getting the Queen out of the
way and also putting pressure on the
rope here so the Queen for the moment is
stuck guarding the rook and if you can
get something like Bishop to d6 in e4
and Queen to g3 then that's pretty much
it for black also there will be threats
on h2 also if white advances advances
the point and maybe you can get the rook
into the attack as well
so here and it pushes c5 he says that
Bishop is not coming in into the game
and also ideas like d6 are now on the
board of course d6 d7 you want to push
as many points as possible maybe you if
the rook moves maybe you can even
sacrifice the a six point to have a two
connected passports here there are a lot
of ideas here and the sacrum sacrifice
is definitely worth White's position
so here Kasparov pushes efore pushes the
LightSquared Bishop back with Bishop to
e2 and the now comes rook the e5 so this
is how Kasparov goes for the rook lift
now the rook can come to g5 also you're
just threatening to pick up the pawn
here and you have to be careful if you
advance the pawn than just Bishop
captures that you will not be able to
recapture due to the pin so we have
Queen to d7 now defending the pawn this
way also threatening to pick up the b7
point if you lose the b7 pawn then the
three passed pawns are definitely
decisive so here Kasparov goes rook to
g5 also
valiant attempt was III opening up an
attack on the on the rookin b1 and after
the rook moves now you go rook to e7 I
push the Queen back you defend the b7
point after the Queen retreats queen g4
now of course white will more than
gladly go into the same game rookie for
you can play characters captures and now
d6 and white white is just much better
here and it will be extremely hard to
guard that b7 pawn so here Kasparov
doesn't like this he goes rook to g5
instead we have attacking the g2 pawn
rook to g1 and now III we have these six
are now advancing the pawn and then now
comes Luke to g3 here Kasparov is
threatening some ideas but for the
moment they are not possible white is
much better here clearly we have Queen
captures on b7 and now Kasparov plays
Queen to ecigs it is the last attempt
you can try in this position since well
of course if you captured the rook then
the rook captures and h3 is just mate
after Queen captures on h3 but of course
Anand did not capture the rook here
Anand just played King to h2 and it was
in this position that Garry Kasparov
resigned the game on on move 35 in game
nine of their 1995 match since now
there's really nothing to do here the
rook is under attack you have to you
have to move it and also this rook is
under attack so there's really nothing
nothing to be done here even if you try
well maybe if this rook wasn't hanging
then maybe you could have some tricks
with Bishop captures and these six but
still very unlikely and also you could
try it something like this to go for
some sneaky discoveries but there really
aren't any white can just pick it up and
you don't have a good discovery here yes
you can play rook rook something but
whatever you do now it simply doesn't
work you could try rook captures with
the Czech team captures and now well you
don't have any any useful checks to try
and create a perpetual so here the white
would just to easily get out of checks
and that that's just it you have to
resign so after King 2h - Erika Sparrow
resigned and Anand wins this game so
like I said we already covered
Arnon versus anand the 2013 Tata Steel
that brilliant brilliant game a game for
the ages
Allen's favorite game also I Magnus said
on few occasions that it's also his his
favorite Anand game but I thought that
this was just taking down Kasparov in
1995 is just amazing and especially in a
game that at least seems this effortless
it's just beautiful stuff the the
celebration did not last long since out
of the next five games Kasparov was able
to win four and and drew one but in the
end you know
Kasparov did win the match 10 and after
seven and a half but this game remains
and it just shows what a what a great
player Anand Anand was and still is a he
still even though he's fifty years of
age competing on the highest level in
every possible time format and also I
did prepare a nice photo of the two
legends so here it is I let's just enjoy
that for a brief moment there it is a
beautiful photo I don't know who who the
photo is from it's just you know
circulating online so let's just enjoy
that for a minute there you have it and
oh yeah yeah I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed my my pic of the
game for 450 birthday really there were
a lot of games to choose from obviously
but I just thought this one is well just
taking down Kasparov so effortlessly in
a in a match well in one of the games in
the match is just I I thought worth
worth worth checking out now as well
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
do check out the link I provided in the
description below the first one and also
do join the subscribers video if you
don't know what it is check the second
link in the description below and be a
part of it it will be awesome so I would
like to thank Michael Larson Eduardo
JPEG Waga
Bronco Kenichi Jared Stein and the
Michael Francis genie for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it but Uncle cringe is
actually my uncle I had no idea he was
following the channel so thanks for that
we're gonna have a beer you know as soon
as I manage the time and yeah as usual
you can check to my previous videos
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check
your wonderful suggestions and we are
starting the coverage of the of the
feeder Grand Prix so thank you all I
will see you soon and once again happy
50th birthday refer not an island